The idea of finding a new planet is always
so appealing and exciting!
But what if a rogue planet just, kinda, wandered
into our Solar System?
Hey, it might have already happened!
Hey guys, space-fan Amy with you on DNews
today.
Last year, astronomers at CalTech announced
the discovery of a potential new planet, Planet
Nine.
We’ve talked about it before: it’s a hypothetical
planet whose existence has been theorized
by observations of distant Kuiper Belt objects.
Six of these small bodies are tracing out
similarly irregular orbits around the Sun
suggesting there’s some big gravitational
mass tugging on them: Planet Nine.
If it exists, it’s between ten times the
mass of Earth and the mass of Neptune, orbits
some 1,000 Astronomical Units away, so 1,000
times further from the Sun than the Earth,
and has an inclined orbit.
The question then, is, how could a planet
that big have formed that far away with such
an odd orbit?
Well, new research from a team at New Mexico
State University says that it might not have
formed in our system, it might have been captured.
We might have taken in an orphaned interloper
of a planet!
We tend to think of a planet as orbiting a
star, but according to a previous study out
of the Osaka University in Japan, rogue planets
are actually fairly common; 75 percent of
all Jupiter-mass planets might be free-floating
in space!
The astronomers came to this number using
a method called gravitational microlensing.
This technique involves measuring how much
a massive object warps the light from a distant
star as seen from Earth.
Usually used to find a planet orbiting a distant
star, astronomers found some odd instances
of microlensing in data sets.
The data was consistent with a planet passing
in front of a star, but there was no signal
linking it to a host star.
Their conclusion was that these planets are
free-floating rogues, wandering alone through
space.
And there were a lot of them!
This team found ten in two years, suggesting
there are potentially twice as many rogue
planets as planets in solar systems in the
milky way alone.
Ok.
So if this is true — remember we’re in
hypotheticals right now — could Planet Nine
be a captured rogue?
The team from New Mexico State carried out
156 simulations of solar system encounters
with a rogue planet hitting our system at
an inclined angle and found that it’s possible!
In 50 percent of the simulations, the rogue
encountered the system and was simply slingshotted
out on its way.
Only occasionally — 10 percent of the time
— did a rogue passing through rip another
planet out of the system with it, creating
a new rogue.
But in 40 percent of encounter simulations,
the rogue became part of the system.
There are a couple of ways this could happen.
With a planet the mass of Neptune — which
is about 17 times the mass of Earth and within
the range Planet Nine is thought to be -- it
would be a “soft capture.”
The rogue would start orbiting the Sun without
disrupting the solar system at all.
If the planet was more massive, say, the mass
of Jupiter, which is about 318 times the mass
of Earth, the rogue would make an exchange.
It would enter our system but fling another
planet out in it’s stead.
An even bigger rogue three times the mass
of Jupiter would have a more devastating effect.
The rogue would be massive enough to kick
two or more planets out of the system.
It could even boot everyone out!
Obviously that last one didn’t happen, but
still.
Rogue planets are real, and it’s possible
that they shaped the Solar System we know
and love, and one might have joined us on
its journey!
Speaking of interlopers, if NASA were to find
alien interlopers, would it tell us?
I dig into the history of this question over
on Vintage Space.
And there’s more on Planet Nine right here.
Do you guys love or hate the idea of Planet
Nine being a captured rogue?
Let us know in the comments below, be sure
to like this video and subscribe so you never
miss an episode of DNews.